you're the batman so you're fast
justice league snyder cut is eight years
in the making
and what in eight years it's been from
tragedy to fan campaigns and everything
in between
the production of this four-part movie
is basically a film itself
so what did the behind the scenes of
this hbo cut look like
and how close did snyder really come to
filming the batman and joker scene in
his own backyard
snyder cut isn't just an added bonus for
fans of the dc universe
there's a deeper meaning and reasoning
as to why the film was even made
but first let's dive into how they
actually brought the film to life
i mean we have to try don't we we have
to try
we could all agree that jason momoa has
been a truly epic
addition to dc hands down but when we
found out what it actually looks like
when he's filming his water scenes
we couldn't hold back our laughter take
a look
it's just such a drastic difference from
what we see in the final version that we
couldn't help but be taken aback
apparently jason had no control of his
body when he was filming these scenes
he was attached to a robotic arm and rig
so they could coordinate his movements
the way they wanted
the best part they had to tie his hair
back into a hair net so they could use
vfx to really control the way it moved
underneath the water
kudos to momoa on this one and then you
look back at him
if you think momoa had it bad while
filming those scenes he's also admitted
that going to the washroom wasn't the
easiest while wearing his costume
and his trident well that would leave
him sore for days after a shoot that
involved fighting with it
but that's just the tip of the iceberg
when it comes to how uncomfortable the
justice league's costumes can be
amber heard literally had to be vacuum
sealed into her mirror suit
and the first time ezra miller put on
the flash costume it was so constricting
he couldn't even lift his arm over his
head
yeah i
i need friends just by looking at wonder
woman's suit
you can tell it's not the most
comfortable thing to be in
but listen to gal gadot recount just how
excruciating it was to wear
it was so tight and i literally could
not
breathe but ben affleck is one-upping
her by telling people he had to have six
crew members zip him up into the bat
suit before filming the most comfortable
one in snyder's cut
might just have been jared leto's joker
whose costume looks so comfortable
even we wouldn't mind trying it on you
might have noticed that his costume and
makeup were
even more simple than what we saw in his
last appearance in suicide squad
snyder says that's because his one scene
takes place in batman's nightmares
batman one major difference between
justice league and snyder cut
how hands-on snyder was as a director
behind the scenes
we're talking like completely into it as
if he was about to film the scene
alongside the actors
in the behind the scenes footage you can
see how he would explain moves and
choreography and placement step by step
to each actor
half the time he was next to them when
the cameras were rolling and we never
even knew
and you can bet he was 100 proud of his
work
so proud that when someone asked him if
he would be using any footage
that joss whedon had shot his response
was i would set it on fire
before i use a single frame that i did
not photograph
some would call him dramatic but we're
choosing to call him dedicated
okay that dedicated attitude he had is
probably what set the tone for how happy
and laid-back set life was for the cast
while they were filming under his
direction
the behind the scenes outtakes and
bloopers will show you just how much of
a family this cast was
however when the dynamic changed with
joss whedon
gal gadot admits that things weren't the
same during the reshoots
when asked how the experience was
working with whedon she said it honestly
wasn't that great
i had my own experience with him which
wasn't the best one
but like the independent woman she is
she took care of it
we can't help but wonder how much of the
set's atmosphere transferred into the
movie
and maybe played a role in all the
negative reviews the original justice
league received
i'm so sorry let's all take a moment to
think about how much technology has
changed
since 2016. a lot
apple was only at the iphone 7 when
justice league was first released
wild and while this definitely befitted
snyder
it was extremely difficult to get all
the archived vfx work out of storage and
transferred into the programs they'd be
using
after everything was said and done they
only had six short months
to recreate half of all the movies vfx
including characters like dark seed who
weren't even included in the original
the hardest thing to bring to life in
the editing room steffenwolf
and we can definitely see why luckily
the editing department managed to dodge
having to edit superman's mustache again
if you like the original justice league
you'll remember the uproar around his
creepily edited upper lip
here's a peek at the time of reshoots
henry cavill had a contract with
paramount to keep his mustache
but all of snyder's footage happened
pre-mustache
well i guess i do want one we mentioned
that joker had an appearance in snyder's
cut
but it almost didn't happen snyder was
desperate to somehow have this scene
included even if the actors had to film
it in his backyard
he even told ben affleck let's just do
to my house i could shoot it in the
backyard
but there'd be no backyard shoot warner
brothers finally caved and let him shoot
the scene in studio
it's the only moment not part of the
original footage the cool thing is that
ben affleck and jared leto had
conflicting schedules and didn't even
shoot on the same day
the scene was pieced together in the
editing room later on
i'll be the bigger man the music and
snyder's cut is also
all new musician junkie axel no longer
enjoyed the music for the original film
so he spent six months creating a score
in the spare bedroom of his home
in the midst of a pandemic impressive he
says
there were days i woke up in the morning
i didn't know how i was going to finish
it
well we're glad he did another perk for
snyder getting his cut on hbo was that
he got to air it in the format he
originally wanted it in
you might have noticed that the 4-part
movie isn't available in widescreen and
only 4-3 it's all part of the creative
vision
and snyder wanted to make sure it'd be
able to be shown on an imac screen one
day
it's already here the truth is snydercut
was never meant to make it to any
screens whatsoever
director zack snyder was signed on to
the original justice league back in
2016.
tragedy struck at home after the passing
of his daughter
he decided to step away and his version
of justice league was re-shot and
reshaped
to match director joss whedon's vision
but when fans heard that there was a
version of justice league that was true
to snyder's vision
they joined forces and petitioned to
have it released
like actually petitioned they managed to
get
thousands of signatures and the support
of ben affleck and amber heard
warner brothers just couldn't deny them
any longer and bourne was the deal with
hbo
if you pay attention you'll see that the
four-part movie is actually
dedicated to snyder's daughter at the
end of the film it reads
for autumn without her this absolutely
would not have happened
snyder's cut on hbo was definitely the
better option for the footage than what
was originally going to happen with it
snyder admits he was just gonna use it
as some cool videos on his laptop to
share with friends
you see i believe enemies are coming
stop right there i'm in
no one can say there wasn't a tremendous
amount of effort from not only snyder
and his crew
but the fans of the dc universe this
project is the actual definition
of dedication it's amazing to think
about how perfect and polished snyder's
cut
ended up looking despite all the
hardships it faced to even get made
and the music being produced in a
bedroom mind blowing
what are your thoughts on the newest
addition to the dc collection